hello steve here again steve kaufman and
today i have the pleasure of speaking
with an online teacher of russian
daria of real russian club remember if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications if
you follow me on
podcast service please leave a review
okay daria
i'm going to ask you to introduce
yourself and then i have a number of
questions that i would like to ask you
i want to start with it
the the word that horrifies all the
beginners in russian
uh so yeah i'm a teacher you said i'm an
online teacher but also i am a teacher
at the university at cu boulder
so i teach offline i teach online and i
try to find this balance to find this
perfect way of learning russian for
people who learn with teacher
with a teacher for people who learn
by themselves on their own
so yeah that's that's pretty much what i
try to do
okay we will leave a link to your
youtube channel in the description box
um
so there was a very famous hungarian
polyglot
kato la lam or lom kato who said who had
a formula for language learning which
essentially was
that it's a it's a function of the
motivation of the learner
the time put in
divided by
inhibition frustration difficulty and
everything that reduces the level of
motivation so my first question is
how do you what do you do to increase
the motivation
for people to learn
russian and what do you do to decrease
the difficulties real or imagined
that are there in the russian language
first of all i think the most important
thing is to use the materials that are
interesting for students
it's hard to do it online but offline i
always try to
ask in very
first
how to say on the very first lessons i
try to ask some personal questions what
they like what they are interested in
like somebody uh can be interested in
you know science or chemistry somebody
might like motorcycles somebody's a fan
of harry potter or lord of the rings or
star wars or anything so at the very
beginning when people cannot deal with
authentic russian materials as much i
try to use
something they like
in russian for example we are going to
use star wars characters in russian so
making dialogues between i don't know
darth vader and yoda
completely made up of course
um so something that would keep people
engaged rather than using random
characters like some silvio from italy
comes to russia and he interacts or
something like that so when it's
something
uh more funny uh it's it's just more
engaging
and i encourage people when they learn
on their own to do the same thing rather
than using something
that they don't care about
like articles about weather or something
like that
use the same materials can i
i just want to pick up on that because i
think you make a very important point
so many of these beginner books talk
about
you know mario comes from italy he's at
the train stations with you know customs
he goes to the bank he goes to the
doctor and all of these are totally
uninteresting and typically the narrator
is bored reading the story and so that's
a very bad place to start
and what you're suggesting is things
that are not only of interest to your
learners but also familiar to them i
think it's very important to deal with
material that is familiar and another
problem sometimes in language text is
they go to the very esoteric cultural
aspects of korean or japanese or russian
whereas really they should be beginning
with as you said you know harry potter
or star wars or or something that is
already familiar so we can go from the
familiar to the less familiar because
already the language is of course not
familiar
yes
i totally agree with what you said
and you mentioned boring narrators this
is a huge problem because
especially those older books that have
audio with them it seems as it as if
some robots were reading those texts it
it is awful
so in my podcasts uh in my audio lessons
i always try to use as many emotions as
i can so when it's like whispering or
yelling or so i try to to be engaging
because when it's an audio lesson it's
even more difficult to to keep your
attention there because you don't see
the person speaking so those uh
monotonous boring uh readings it's uh
very discouraging so he has emotions i
checked out your videos by the way and
they are excellent and they're very
lively and that's exactly what people
need to motivate them
and we learn better there's more
resonance we learn better
yeah so because uh otherwise you'll just
fall asleep after what 10 minutes into
the into the russian text
so yeah materials that are interesting
being more emotional and uh
pleasure first of all so as soon as you
feel discouraged as soon as you feel
overwhelmed do you feel that i'm not
having any progress i am at this point
how to pronounce plato how to pronounce
it plato
in russian we say
oh yeah
yes and it's inevitable yeah it's
inevitable
uh and a lot of people are so
discouraged that they think that this is
the end and they just quit and in
reality it's just the milestone you need
to overcome this point and you will
maybe skyrocket on the next stage
so it's very important
your motivation
while on the subject of the plateau
how do you deal with the experience that
i had with russian and that is that no
matter how many times you look at the
declension table
no matter how many times you look at the
endings
in the three different genders for all
the different cases you can't remember
them
you maybe you can identify
if you're reading
from the context you can identify the
meaning of that word but when you're
speaking to try to get the correct
case ending
no matter how much you study it just
seems so elusive how do you help your
russian learners improve in their use of
cases in russian
oh first of all i try to be very nice
and especially the first stages because
i learned this mostly from my american
students before i used to be this harsh
russian person who corrects all mistakes
you should be perfect it was a long time
ago but that's how it started
unfortunately and then several people
told me that
i made them cry after i was in my nice
i was in my nice stage i thought i was
encouraging but some people told me that
they were so frustrated even with minor
corrections at the beginning that they
were crying and it turned
my whole understanding of it upside down
so after that i am the nicest teacher
ever at the beginning of course
i never correct never correct people i
happy when they say anything to me later
when i hear them
being confident already but when they
make mistakes i will correct them and
then we will concentrate on grammatical
aspects of that but at the beginning
it's important just to try because no
harm done if if you
mix those endings of cases it's very
confusing
even for russian people it's very
confusing and we learn cases at russian
schools being native speakers still for
several years we learn those endings
those questions for the cases it's it's
a difficult thing we can't underestimate
it
so
yeah just slowly trying
i think that's a very important point
that you just made there is a stage in
our learning where we want to be
corrected but at the early stages we
need encouragement we need encouragement
to keep speaking
and many mistakes do correct themselves
conversely many of the corrections that
the teacher makes have no effect
whatsoever
i know that
in different languages if i look at my
sort of
lesson notes i get from my teacher i
make the same mistakes every week so
it's a gradual process combination of
reading the rules and the teacher
correcting you and self-correcting but
it's certainly
there's no quick
solution to these things
and you just have to hope that
eventually the brain gets used to them
but cases are a problem in russian
and how about the other difficulty in
russian which is this whole aspect of
verbs verbs of emotion do you have any
certain secret in
helping people for
for verbs especially verbs of motion
verbs with prefixes i have a special
course for that i try again to put them
into some funny context i create stories
again using harry potter using some
famous actors
uh using
some popular popular characters and i
try to put those verbs into a funny
context funny mini-story and then i will
ask simple questions for every sentence
like
on
the show
and
for 20 minutes straight just repeating
the same stuff again and again and um
since mostly those prefixes keep their
meaning for most of the verbs after 10
minutes stories like that this is this
just gets somewhere deep in your memory
and next time you click and you use it
naturally because you heard it and
repeated it so many times you just have
the feeling of when you want to go out
you say visual
so
it's just the point of practice and
hearing the same thing again and again
in the same situations but with
different
different characters
and and there's no predicting when all
of a sudden we start being able to use
some of these things correctly
so sometimes it's a bit it's the same as
trying to remember words certain
vocabulary items just never stick
and
we shouldn't allow ourselves to be
frustrated and the same with with
grammar we shouldn't allow ourselves to
be frustrated at some point it will
probably click in
and
i think your your approach of patience
repetition but not being too demanding
of people makes a lot of sense
um
one final note
so i think
russia if we today in the world if we
look at the most popular languages you
know languages that are peop that people
are learning
obviously english is probably number one
because of its practical your usefulness
and then
historically certain european languages
like spanish
are popular and
recently korean and japanese have become
popular for reasons related to pop
culture and so forth and so on
i mean i happen to be a fan of the 19th
century so russian for me was very
attractive
uh and of course russia is an enormous
country with uh
not only not only sort of the original
slavic russian people but it's the whole
influence of central asia and the
caucuses and it's a spectacular world
this whole russian world thing that's me
what is most attractive to your students
what brings them to russian
oh
today it's a very complicated question
because unfortunately what i notice uh
in the past decade
the interest to the russian language is
is decreasing unfortunately and uh more
and more often each new semester at the
university i see that it's some people
that are interested in
military stuff so there are people in in
uniforms sitting in class i'm oh okay
it's it's not a good reason to learn
russian but
but unfortunate so this is one reason i
guess a lot of military people are
suddenly very interested in russia
but
peaceful people usually are
interested in
literature i heard that but this is this
is rare because people are realistic
they understand that
uh from the point of start and learning
the language to
the point where they will be able to
read the stayefsky or
war and peace tolstoy
in original this is this is a huge way
so
um
what else a lot of people have parents
from russian-speaking countries from the
former soviet union countries
and they start to forget the language
they start to speak with accent they
confuse the words
so those people come a lot to my classes
a lot of people come to just do it for
fun
yeah that's true i mean maybe maybe uh
if there were some you know russian
equivalent of anime or k-pop
that would encourage people to learn
russian uh just on the subject of okay i
said that i was interested in 19th
century literature but i'm learning
arabic right now and i came across this
uh
cartoon series
from jordan
therefore in levantine arabic on youtube
three to five minutes long cartoons
about this family and there's three kids
and the kids are teasing each other and
the
typical struggles between husband and
wife and and it's just so well done and
it's so amusing
and it comes with either english or um
arabic subtitles and each episode is
three to five minutes long and there's
like an endless number of these and it's
just struck me and i'm using them for my
levantine arabic and these are
phenomenal for language learning
phenomenal you can watch it with english
subtitles it's three or five minutes
long you can then read through the
dialogue which i do on link you can
listen to it and it's funny it's
familiar it's a family situation it
doesn't matter whether you're in jordan
or russia or canada
family dynamics are kind of similar
so it's it's a spectacular learning
material resource
i don't know whether anything like that
exists for russian and even the fact
that it's cartoons makes it lighter
and and fun and the voices i mean the
actors you know the voices are wonderful
and it's just excellent and it's it's
dialogue rich uh there's no one watching
a movie where there's lots of
you know scenery and silence or or
shooting or door slamming you need like
dialogue-rich content that's amusing and
familiar and these certainly do that
but i don't know if anything similar
exists for russian
yeah we do have a lot of russian
cartoons they are originally made for
russians of course for russian children
my son loved them when he was smaller uh
it's trikata three cats it's about three
kittens and their parents and all those
family interaction situations are there
like going to school having an argument
with your siblings or parents making
some surprise celebrating birthdays all
this stuff in quite simple russian
because it's for small children
so trikata is the first moleshariki is
the second does it have english very
cute
i'm sure something that would be that
would be worth looking into because i
i've found these for the for my 11th in
arabic it's it's just phenomenal as a
learning material
better than any uh you know teach
yourself living in a russian you know
textbook anyway yes cartoons are amazing
are amazing yeah well listen we could go
on forever i think but uh as i said i'm
leaving a link to your channel i think
russian is a phenomenal language to
learn it's one-seventh of the globe if
you look at it on a map of the world
russian interacts or intersects with
other countries where russian was or is
still spoken it's a gateway to all the
slavic languages
it has a rich literature it's a
wonderful sounding language very
creative people i very much encourage
people to learn russian and to learn
with daria and go to her youtube channel
and see how she can help you
so darya thank you very much for being
with me today
and i look forward to chatting again
nice video thank you so much parker